so I'm going to have some sort of
wrap-up and highlights of this extremely
erratic behavior from our president over
the weekend this includes continuing the
farce that is Sharpie gait this includes
authoritarian demands that Noah not
contradict and oaa that is Noah not
contradict his claims about Hurricane
Dorian putting Alabama at risk but
before we even get to that because I do
want to run through some of those
stories a little bit we're now learning
and it makes sense that Donald Trump's
own advisors the brown-nosing sycophants
who will stand behind the guy until the
most extenuating and absurd
circumstances make it all but impossible
to defend him even Trump's own advisors
are starting to privately say that
they're worried about Donald Trump's
mental state after this last week of
just outrageously erratic and volatile
behavior so we see the public part the
unhinged tweet storms the confused slow
speeches while he seems to be gripping
the POE to the electors and wrestling
with his own tongue the angry speeches
but that's just the public side and
there's the behind-the-scenes which is
an entire other situation going on
privately which Donald Trump's aides
are now coming clean about Trump's aides
and confidants are now telling business
insider that he is experiencing bipolar
mood changes and I don't mean bipolar in
the psychiatric sense I mean bipolar in
terms of up and down up and down mood
changes from one minute to the next
based sometimes merely on seeing a news
headline that he doesn't like this guy
is so trigger Abha land so volatile that
sometimes according to his own aides and
advisers his entire schedule will be
changed because he sees some negative
story about him which sends him into a
complete and total tailspin such that
he's unable to do or unwilling to do
anything for the rest of the day quote
from one Republican strategist who was
frequently in contact with the White
House he's deteriorating in plain sight
we see it publicly right just by itself
what we see publicly would be enough to
confirm that this is someone who is
temper mentally unfit
President of the United States and aides
are saying that the public component is
nothing compared to the private
component a person whose clothes who was
close to Donald Trump's legal team
during the Russia investigation told a
business insider that Trump's public
statements were quote nothing compared
to what he's like
behind closed doors the Alabama thing
which we've been in because we'll
continue talking about a little bit is
particularly worrying to them because it
could have all been prevented by saying
oh I mentioned Alabama could have been
hit by the hurricane
turns out hurricane durian wasn't
heading there we should all be glad
about that that people in Alabama
weren't in harm's way we're gonna work
on helping the people who were in harm's
way
instead it has been this endless
never-ending lies and cover-ups
including drawing on a hurricane map
with a sharpie which we talked about
last week so this is no longer about
Donald Trump lying
Trump's aides and confidants are saying
everyone is used to the lies already sad
that we've become completely accustomed
to that but that this Alabama thing has
crossed over to another level altogether
that is to to them to quote them quote a
deterioration in plain sight 15 tweets
and 5 maps about the Alabama Hurricane
Fiasco and this is unfortunately and I
mean that it's not a surprise to anyone
who's been watching or listening to my
program and paying attention to this
he's been getting worse and worse and
worse for years now and he controls
nuclear weapons and geopolitics and our
relationships to every historical world
a lie of importance to the United States
if he merely stays on the same
trajectory like nothing gets worse but
nothing accelerates he just stays on the
same decline trajectory between now and
Election Day
imagine what we will be dealing with by
November of 2020 especially if his
polling numbers don't improve and an
even more deteriorated Donald Trump
believes that he's likely to lose in
November of 2020 this will become the
stuff of nightmares and just imagine if
he starts to think that as a result of
losing in November of 2020 he might end
up indicted it will be more outrageous
than weekend like
imagine he will be desperate to prove
non-existent voter fraud he will be
desperate to avoid the possibility of
indictment and maybe just as importantly
for him global embarrassment as a result
of that indictment there's actually an
interesting split kind of developing in
the Trump supporter camp although they
all are still likely to vote for him in
2020 you've got on one side the trumpets
who are sort of doubling down and
they're pretending that everything
Trump's doing is normal that any
critique of Trump is merely fake news
meant to take down a president who won't
stop winning that's the double down
trumpets but you've got this other wing
of trumpets developing there the
trumpets who realize they made a mistake
in supporting this existential threat to
humanity and they have just stopped
paying attention to Donald Trump and use
headlines they're sort of pretending
that the president what oh I you know I
just work I go and live my life I
haven't heard of any of it they're sort
of struggling to remain ignorant
deliberately and uninformed for their
own benefit and to placate their
cognitive dissonance those are the two
sides unlikely either side is ultimately
going to vote for a Democrat but we'll
talk about that and now let's get into
the specifics of the insanity that this
weekend saw